[Music]
hello welcome to 3abn today Bible q a my
name is Angela Loma King I'm glad that
you've tuned in today and we are excited
about this program anytime we go into
the word of God it's a blessing there's
a song that says word of God speak and
truly the word of God is going to speak
to us today amen
before we go on I thank you for your
support of this ministry and for you
mostly for your prayers would we be
without your prayers thank you we it is
much appreciated well I'd like to
introduce our illustrious panel
right next to me is my wonderful
sweetheart J well he's he's like a
nephew to me okay Jason Bradley welcome
Jason thank you it's great to be here
and you know we're going to be studying
the Bible together so this is wonderful
yes isn't it don't you learn a lot when
you I do because sometimes the questions
that come in it just it makes you search
through God's word it may be something
that we didn't think of before exactly
so we go searching for the answers yeah
and the word speaks doesn't it
absolutely next to you is beautiful
Shelley Quinn welcome to leave for that
we just want to thank you for sending in
your questions because as Jason said
it's our privilege to make certain that
the answers coming from scripture and
you get some good answers around here do
you learn a lot also oh of course we all
we all do the word of God is
inexhaustible yes absolutely and in
front of me the love of my life my
darling that's right Pastor John McCain
how was the love of my life doing I'm
wonderful let's stop flirting on
internet I know right but hey glad to
have your honey hosting the program and
as always the Bible is um it's a it's an
inexhaustible Warehouse you go in there
and you think that wow so many people
read in the Bible how could that
possibly be yeah God's word is never
exhausted but it does exhaust us
good thing about it is he gives us the
answers that we need in order to always
give glory and honor to his name and
thank you for sending your questions in
oh thank you now let me explain how this
program is all three of these guests
have questions and how many questions we
have up for oh about four years four
questions each and three of them it take
they'll use three minutes to answer
those questions and one question is four
minutes so if you have a question and
you would like to send your questions in
you can send you can text us at
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv and if you're an Instagram
person you can Instagram us at 3abn
underscore official
now I'd like to ask one of my guests to
open with prayer Shelly would you please
oh surely
holy and righteous father our hearts
just
overflow with your love we are so
grateful to you for your plan of
salvation by grace we're grateful for
Jesus we're grateful for your Holy
Spirit and thank you for your word you
did not leave us as orphans so now send
your Holy Spirit speak through us may we
lift Jesus high that he may draw all
unto himself
Christ we pray amen
man thank you Shelley now get your
Bibles out
first question is going to be to you
honey hey wow
it's going to be you this is a big
loaded question
boy do we have three minutes to answer
this I hope so here goes what is the
mock of the Beast okay this is a 30
minute question no thank you for that
question let me go ahead and start
reading in Revelation 13 where primarily
the uh the content of this question
comes from Revelation 13 verses 16 to
18.
he
speaking of the second beast of
Revelation chapter 13 which represents
the United States causes all both small
and great rich and poor free and bond
to receive a mark on their right hand or
on their foreheads and that no one may
buy or sell except one who has the Mark
or the name of the Beast or the number
of his name
so when you look at those two verses
verses 16 and I said to 18 I'll just do
16 and 17. you find something that's
very significant that I want to
emphasize very quickly it says he causes
it doesn't say he's the one that marks
he causes all both small and great to
receive a mark now
what we know is going to happen in the
near future this is this is um
politically economically socially and
religiously there are going to be
enactments in America that are going to
limit the very things that we have today
including religious freedom and there's
a movement underfoot
where people are going to be told that
they have to follow a certain way of
believing and thinking in order to be in
harmony with what the nation has
accepted as the way that the government
in its economic as well as in its
religious manner has merged together
because Revelation 13 pictures the
resurrected power of Rome
merged with the political powers of the
United States the land-like nation
we know that when the enactments to
worship a certain way becomes imposed
upon men through laws then for those who
impose for those who oppose the
imposition will be considered quote
unquote enemies of the state now I do
believe that there's going to be some
kind of way whether electronically or
financially that people will be weeded
out for example today
many of us we go and travel around the
world we do and you know if you have a
when we went to certain parts of the
world and during covid we had to have a
a QR code on our phone to get into
certain countries if that code was green
you can get in if it was not green you
couldn't get in you will you were not
allowed in I believe that somehow
there's going to be a counterfeit Mark
that men are going to establish to
counteract the real Mark that God is in
charge of because if the devil was in
charge of given the mark of the beast
he'll give it to everyone but something
gets put in place where he causes all
both small and great rich and poor free
and bond to receive the mark and when
you go all the way to the very beginning
of the Bible do you find that one of the
very first marks given there was a mark
put upon Cain to protect him you also
find there was a mark put upon those who
sigh and cry for the Abominations done
in Jerusalem that was a good Mark so God
knows that they are in harmony with his
will but the Bible talks about the marks
and particularly the mark of the beast
is
a sign of allegiance to a power that
opposes God
and that power Satan that power Satan
aligned with all the forces that align
which will be under the um under the
whole host of Babylon uh coalescing
together right quite a quite an intense
subject we didn't have enough time
matter of fact I have two sermons called
The Mark of the Beast part one and part
two you can find that on YouTube or
Church website yes and when it comes to
end time stuff you love that that's yeah
thank you okay Shelly this is an
interesting question
this is from a person in Malawi and they
sent it through Instagram our only
Seventh-Day Adventists going to heaven
absolutely not the name over your church
whatever's on your church building
doesn't
earn you
eternal life there's only one way what
matters if you want eternal life is to
be in Christ Jesus John 1 12 says as
many as received him to them he gave the
right to become children of God to those
who believe in his name all who have
entered into Covenant with God the
Everlasting Covenant of righteousness by
faith become children of God we know
that God makes and keeps all of his
Covenant promises through Christ First
Corinthians 1 20. all of his promises
are yes and amen in Christ but you must
be in Christ Ephesians 1 7 in him in
Christ we have Redemption through his
blood the Forgiveness of sins according
to the riches of his grace Ephesians 1
11 in him we've tamed and inheritance
being predestined according to the
purpose of him who works all things
according to the counsel of his will
Romans chapter 5 and verse 1 having been
justified by faith we have peace with
God through our Lord Jesus Christ John
5-6 I am the vine you are the branches
he who abides in me who remains in me
and I in him Bears much fruit for
without me you can do nothing but if
anyone does not abide or remain in me he
is cast out as a branch in his withered
and they gather them and throw them into
the fire and they are burn Jesus said so
here's the point God expects his
Covenant children to he makes and keeps
all the promises but he invites us to
enter into Covenant and he expects
loyalty to him and to his government of
love he expects us to walk in obedience
first Thessalonians 4 verse 3 says this
is the will of God your sanctification
he didn't come to only rid us of the
penalty of sin but to separate us from
the power of sin John 14
15-16 Jesus said if you love me keep my
Commandments and I will pray the father
he will give you another helper that he
may abide with you forever Romans 8 14
as many as are led by the spirit of God
that means you're going to be walking in
obedience these are sons of God now
here's the point God has a people in
every Church right but he is calling on
his people to come out of those churches
that practice men's Traditions he calls
them Babylon he does not want us to
worship according to man's Traditions
Revelation 18 4 he says I heard another
voice from Heaven saying come out of her
my people lest you share in her sins
unless you receive of her plagues a
million times amen very good and he says
my people yes and my people hear my
voice right yes I will follow the
shepherd thank you for that oh well said
beautiful answers Jason here we go
boy this is an interesting one what is
the difference between Fallen Angels and
Demons
the short answer is there is no
difference between Fallen Angels and
Demons fallen angels and demons are one
and the same and they're used
interchangeably throughout scripture the
word Angel simply means messenger so
let's consider Revelation chapter 12
verses 7 through 9 and war broke out in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon and his
angels fought but they did not Prevail
nor was a place found for them in heaven
any longer so the Great Dragon was cast
out that Serpent of old called the devil
and Satan who deceives the whole world
he was cast to the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him the devil's
Fallen Angels or demons are his
Messengers they do his bidding and
they're basically like spiritual
terrorists if you will yeah first Peter
chapter 5 verse 8 says be sober be
vigilant because your adversary the
devil walks about like a roaring lion
seeking whom he may devour I want us to
look at the contrast between the mission
of the enemy and the mission of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ John chapter 10
verse 10 says the thief does not come
except to steal and to kill and to
destroy I have come that they may have
life and that they may have it more
abundantly in Jude chapter 1 verse 6 it
says and and the angels who did not keep
their proper domain but left their own
Abode he has reserved in Everlasting
chains under Darkness for the Judgment
of the great day I say all that to say
that demons and fallen angels are one
and the same amen and they're real
aren't they yes they are yeah very and
they on this Earth Satan was cast down
to this earth not just him who else his
angels demons have mercy that's why you
need to be close to the Lord amen okay
thank you Jason well said okay pastor
Loma King this is your four minute
question and this question it means
something to us because we're we lived
in Brooklyn oh yeah okay and that's
where the headquarters was all right
here we go
how can I explain to my friend who is a
Jehovah Witness that Jesus is God
Capital God here we go yeah I have sent
this to many people thank you so much I
have sent this uh study to many people
and the problem with believing that
Jesus is not God it puts us in a
quandary that I don't think that we
theologically really think about when
you consider that if you say that Jesus
is not God then you're saying then he
was created right and the Creator cannot
save the creation no no sorry the
Creator is the only one that can save
The Creation The Creation can't save the
creation so either he was
either he is the creator or he is the
created he cannot be both so let's look
at the Book of John I had one actually
one leader I was studying with somebody
who was locked down by a person a
religious Pastor who said
The Book of John shouldn't be in the
Bible he wanted to get rid of the entire
Book of John because the Book of John
unequivocally yeah identifying Jesus as
the word who is God he said that book
should not be in the Bible but the good
news is she left that movement and
became a Seventh-Day Adventist Christian
because the word of God is clear now
let's look at some of the evidences that
he is God
start with Mark chapter 2 verse 7. I
could start with John 1 1. matter of
fact I'll do that John 1 1. in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God
either
the Word was God or it wasn't I am
clear enough to take God's word as it
says that's right the Word was God the
word was with God and so you find in the
beginning in the in the beginning
Genesis 1 1 in the beginning God created
the heavens and the Earth and then when
they created man let us make man in our
image according to our likeness and then
when man sinned let us go down for there
become like one of us and what did the
devil tell Eve you shall be like God
knowing good and evil so he wouldn't be
connecting that label
to what man could possibly be had he not
known that Divinity is God
you and so the Bible says they'll be
they have become like one of us that's
not speaking of one individual that's
speaking about the godhead in his
totality but now you go to the
prediction of the coming of Jesus Isaiah
9 verse 6. and this is just a a
three-minute four-minute way that I
could bring this to to fruition
Isaiah 9 6 For unto us a child is born
this is the condescension of Jesus not
the Inception of Jesus this is not how
he came into existence but this is him
coming to Earth in the form of humanity
taken on human flesh For unto us a child
is born unto us a son is given and the
government shall be upon a soul his
shoulder and his name will be called
wonderful counselor the Mighty God
Everlasting father prince of peace now
knowing Jehovah's Witness as well and
having done this study they say he's
Mighty God and God the father is
almighty god well that's not scriptural
let's go to Revelation 1 verse 7 and 8.
behold he is coming with clouds and
every eye will see him even they who
pierced him and all the tribes of the
earth will mourn because of him even so
amen and then declaring of himself I am
the Alpha and the Omega the beginning
and the end says the Lord who is and who
was and who is to come the almighty so
you can't take that from at all and then
you find also
that um Matthew 1 verse 23 speaking a
virgin shall conceive and shall bear a
son and they shall call his name
Emmanuel which translated means god with
us so very quickly if you look at that
and lastly Hebrews 1 verse 8.
but to the son this is the father
speaking but through the son he says
your throne o God is forever and ever a
scepter of righteousness is the scepter
of your kingdom and when you study the
what the prophet says about Jesus it
says he's from Everlasting to
Everlasting and um I don't see any
evidence in scripture where Jesus is a
created being some people try to make
the phrase a begotten of the father that
is not saying the father created Jesus
and then Jesus created everything else
because once again he will be the
created and not the Creator that's my
formative answer to that but suffice it
to say only the Creator
can save the creation and Jesus is in
fact the Creator amen and the Bible says
there's three that bear record in heaven
in first John 5 says okay very quickly
Jason didn't finish his leg let's take
this real quickly yes yes the Pharisees
even themselves said no one can forgive
sin but God and Jesus forgave sin yes
okay
okay Mark 2 Mark 2 verse 7. right only
God Amen thank you thank you okay
Shelley
ah wow this I love this Shelly here's
your four minute question
is there a difference between
justification by faith and righteousness
by faith okay and this doesn't say who
it comes from but we thank you for
sending it in
righteousness by faith is a relational
term it describes a covenant
relationship between us and God
righteousness by faith is how God
relates to us and how we relate to him
righteousness by faith has two aspects
first is justification by faith this
delivers us from the penalty of sin this
is an act of God it happens when we
receive Christ as our savior confess
that we're a sinner and receive his
righteous record of total obedience is
then imputed to us it is credited to our
account our sins are covered and blotted
out by his blood Romans 3
23-24 says all have sinned and fall
short of the glory of God
being
justified freely Justified means to be
declared not guilty
being justified freely by his grace
through the Redemption that is in Christ
Jesus Romans chapter 5 and verse 9 much
more than
having now been justified by his blood
we shall be saved from wrath through him
God declares us not guilty when we
accept Christ as our savior he delivers
us from the penalty of death of sin so
our status
in Christ when we're in Christ it puts
us in right standing with God it
reconciles our relationship with him
that's the first aspect of righteousness
by faith but it doesn't end there you
know the Bible says all unrighteousness
is sin so the second aspect of
righteousness by faith is sanctification
by faith now sanctification is not an
act of God it is a work of God that sets
us apart from sin that delivers us from
the power of sin as Christ
wealth in our hearts
by his infused character his infused
righteousness he dwells in our hearts by
faith through the power of the Holy
Spirit according to Ephesians 3 16. so
what happens is you can't just accept
Christ as your savior and not accept him
as your Lord that's right you can't be
righteous by faith if you just say a
prayer and say oh Jesus I receive you as
my savior no if he's your savior he has
to be your Lord that's right and when we
accept him as our Lord he dwells in our
hearts by faith through the Holy Spirit
delivering us from the power of sin and
I love the way Paul
puts this in second Corinthians 4 11.
he's talking about how we are empowered
to do God's Will and he's referring to
God's righteousness and this is what
Paul says second Corinthians 4 11 that
the life of Jesus Also may be manifested
in our mortal flesh that's right human
beings are mortal beings so here's what
happens as we remain in the lifelong
process we're abiding in Christ
Philippians 2 13 says it is God who
works in you to Will and to do his good
pleasure
Paul says in Philippians 14 or 4 and
verse 13. I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me it is his
infused righteousness Hebrews 8 10 God
says I will put my laws in their mind
and write them on their hearts I will be
their God and they shall be my people so
what God is doing in the process of
righteousness by faith he intends to
make us righteous second Corinthians 5
21 says he made him who knew no sin to
be sin for us that we might become the
righteousness of God in Christ Jesus
he's working in us to recreate the image
of Christ in us that is his goal and
that is righteousness by faith amen he
covers Us with his righteousness he puts
his code on us his blood beautiful well
said you didn't have enough time did you
you'll get to see it okay thank you all
right Jason here we go
what is the meaning of Matthew 7 verse 6
do not give what is Holy to dogs they
will only turn and attack you is that
about not sharing the word or the
gospels with unbelievers this is Justine
from Papua New Guinea ah thank you for
your question Justine let's look at the
verse that you mentioned there Matthew
chapter 7 verse 6. do not give what is
Holy to the dogs nor cast your Pearls
Before Swine unless they trample them
under their feet and turn and tear you
in pieces what a scene let's break it
down do not give what is Holy this is
referring to the sacred teachings of God
now when you think about a dog think
about the nature of a dog a dog chews
toys up he tramples over things he eats
things he shouldn't he uses the restroom
outside well you get the picture
a dog is uninterested in holy teachings
such as matters of Salvation
righteousness by faith the 28
fundamental beliefs Etc a dog just wants
to live for the here and now and is not
concerned about eternal things Proverbs
chapter 26 verse 11 says as a dog
returns to his own vomit so a fool
repeats his folly swine or pigs this the
next part of the verse here are unclean
animals that eat anything that is put in
front of them they consume anything that
will satisfy them in the present moment
if you were to give swine wonderful
Pearls of biblical truth they wouldn't
comprehend it nor would they appreciate
it and they would trample over it
now the turn and attack you portion
think about an individual who hasn't
slept in let's just say days they
haven't slept in in a while right
haven't had much sleep and all of a
sudden you come in and you flip on the
light switch and they get angry at you
because they were resting
comfortably in darkness
some people have grown so comfortable in
their sins that they become hostile when
you flip that switch and you share truth
that would require them to change to
wake up and change now we're definitely
supposed to witness to unbelievers
however we are not supposed to shove the
gospel down someone's throat here's the
principle Matthew chapter 10 verses 11
to 14. now whatever city or town you
enter inquire who in it is worthy and
stay there till you go out
and when you go into a household greet
it if the household is worthy let your
peace come upon it but if it is not
worthy let your peace return to you and
whoever will not receive you nor hear
your words when you depart from that
house or city shake off the dust from
your feet that's right that is one of
the principles there and then Matthew
chapter 10 verse 16 says behold I send
you out as sheep in the midst of wolves
therefore be wise as serpents and
harmless as doves we need to be mindful
of the recipient's attitude and
receptive receptiveness to the gospel
that's right very good and add to that
well said you did your homework praise
God praise the Lord thank you Jason and
we I know oh what's that text there's a
text that we used to say um not say it
was about the dogs oh dog returned to
his vomit what turned Proverbs Yeah you
mentioned that and the Jews were saying
that to Jesus okay
thank you all right honey it's for you
okay here's your question from Dorian
was Jesus hung on a tree or was he
crucified on a cross okay the answer is
six of one and a half dozen of the other
you know it's a rhetorical question
because the answer is actually in the
question
uh the the crosses were not made of
metal or platinum in those days it was
made of wood and most likely the wood
was taken from some tree uh the Bible
doesn't describe exactly what kind of
tree but just some of the historical
background of crucifixion uh the
Persians were the ones to introduce
crucifixion but the Romans were the ones
to to sharpen the impact of crucifixion
on the human body they studied it the
points of almost from a medical point of
view many years ago I think you remember
about 30 years ago I did a sermon on the
crucifixion from a medical point of view
and I remember the congregation being
almost Frozen as one doctor analyzed the
impact of the crucifixion on the body of
Jesus and when that sermon was done I
could hardly find a dry eye in the house
realizing what Christ endured for us he
wasn't just male to a cross and says
okay well you know up here let me just
come down he went through some of the
most ignomonious torture and uh
degradation that anybody could face
but more important than whether or not
it was a tree or whether or not it was
just wood is why he was crucified and to
me that's the more important thing
Isaiah 53 verse 3 to 5 really brings the
picture into full of sense for example
uh
was he hung on a tree or was he
crucified on the cross why was he on the
tree why was he crucified on the cross
Isaiah 53 verse 3 to 5 he was despised
he is despised and rejected by men a man
of sorrow and acquainted with grief and
we hid as it were our faces from him
he was despised and we did not esteem
him surely he has borne our grief griefs
and carried our sorrows yet we esteemed
him stricken Smitten by God and
afflicted
but he was wounded for our
transgressions he was bruised for our
iniquities
the chastisement of our peace was upon
him and by his stripes we are healed
those two verses are so rich I could
just stop and break them down and
consistently speaking about
how people when they realize the the
what Jesus went through they hid their
faces from him and so we get the end the
beautiful picture here
in Romans 5 verse 6 to 10 for when we
were still without Strength In Due Time
Christ died for the ungodly for scarcely
for a righteous man will one dare yet
Perhaps for a good man someone would
even dare to die but God demonstrated
his love toward us in that while we were
yet sinners Christ died for us so
somebody might say was it a tree was it
a cross that's the insignificant portion
did he die for us yes he did and when
they saw it John saw her Jesus says
Behold the Lamb of God that taketh away
the sin of the world that's the real
meaning of what happened on the tree
cross
it was the Majesty of Heaven the Majesty
of Heaven left all for you and for me
thank you
wow Shelly here we go this is an email
no man no name it says according to
First Corinthians 15 40 to 44 at the
Incarnation did Christ take a Heavenly
Body or an Earthly a physical body or a
spiritual one let's read at First
Corinthians 15 40 through 44 and we're
going to look in context to start seeing
our answer there are also celestial
bodies and terrestrial bodies but the
glory of the celestial is one the glory
of the terrestrial is another so in
context Celestial appears to refer to
the Sun the moon and the stars there's
one glory of the sun another glory of
the Moon another glory of the Stars he
says for one star differs from another
star in glory but now now Paul is going
to switch to the terrestrial body that
is in context our natural Earthly bodies
so also is the resurrection of the Dead
the body is sown in corruption when
we're buried it is raised in
incorruption it is sown in dishonor it
is raised in glory sown in weakness race
and power sown a natural body raised a
spiritual body
there is a natural body he says and
there is a spiritual body so the natural
body is the Mortal body now Paul's
choice of words spiritual body the
reason is not reasoning is not entirely
clear but it seems just to be
contrasting the natural mortal body he
says in in First Corinthians 15 46 a
couple of verses down he's talking about
the Natural Body comes first then the
spiritual body he says we bore the image
of the first man Adam we will also bear
the image of The Heavenly Man Christ
Jesus when he tells us in First
Corinthians 15 52 First Corinthians 15
such a dynamite chapter he says in a
moment in the twinkling of an eye at the
last trumpet the trumpet will sound the
dead will be raised Incorruptible we
shall be changed for this corruptable
must put on incorruption this Mortal
must put on immortal so here's the point
Jesus was fully God and fully man yes
that's right we see that in Colossians 1
throughout the Bible he was made in our
likeness he assumed human limitations
when when Mary received the seed of the
Covenant
she received an already existing person
in a seed form who was knit together his
divine nature with her human nature
Hebrews 2 17-18 says in all things he
had to be made like his brethren in all
things that he might be a merciful and
faithful high priest in things
pertaining to God and that he would be
making propitiation for the sins of
people then he it says because he was
himself tempted he's able to Aid those
who are tempted Hebrews 4 15 says our
high priest had all of our weakness he
was tempted in every way yet without sin
he was born as a human baby he had to
grow in stature Luke 2 40 said he grew
and became strong in spirit and he is
fully godfully man when he was on Earth
as the person of Jesus Christ he was in
a natural body amen that's right and
we're not going to heaven with this body
no he was raised in glory we don't have
time to go on so he was raised as a
spiritual body and we will get we will
get one just like him he's in the last
trumpet oh I love that and I'm glad you
said spiritual not the spirit party yeah
yeah a Celestial buddy yes yes amen
looking forward to that great day okay
Jason here's your four minute question
this is an interesting one
how can I be a faithful and Earnest
Seventh-day Adventist Christian If my
spouse is not
he is accepting of my Sabbath and
Sundown observance but he would not be
willing to give up watching TV on
Sabbath should I just should I just
observe Sabbath alone in a different
room this is from Terry
well Terry the first thing I'd like to
address respectfully is the fact that
it's not your Sabbath it's not my
Sabbath it's God's Sabbath and I think
it's important for your husband to see
it in that light as well you know Exodus
chapter 20 verses 8 through 11 we see
the fourth Commandment it says remember
the Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
you shall labor and do all your work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of who
the Lord your God in it you shall do no
work you nor your son nor your daughter
nor your male servant nor your female
servant nor your cattle nor your
stranger who is within your gates for in
six days the Lord made the heavens and
the Earth the sea and all that is in
them and rested the seventh day
therefore the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and hallowed it the second thing
that I want to address is your question
about whether or not you should observe
Sabbath alone in a different room if
your husband is watching secular TV
shows on Sabbath then you should
definitely be in in a different room but
in addition to that I think you should
provide some sabbath-friendly
Alternatives like going for a walk
together in nature enjoying fellowship
with other like-minded believers over
food in a home or a church setting
that's that's actually one of my
favorite things is to enjoy the Sabbath
friendly activities over food and
fellowship that's great visiting the
sick and shut-in or participating in
Outreach in order for your husband to
appreciate and value the Sabbath he
needs to Value the god the lord of the
Sabbath that's right and his
relationship with him I would suggest
spending time introducing your husband
to Jesus and his character by studying
with him throughout their week and
reflecting Christ's character to him
let's take a look at Corinthians chapter
7 First Corinthians chapter 7 verses 10
through 16. now to the married I command
yet not I but the Lord a wife is not to
depart from her husband but even if she
does depart let her remain unmarried or
be reconciled to her husband and a
husband is not to divorce his wife but
to the rest not the Lord I to the rest I
not the Lord say if any brother has a
wife who does not believe and she is
willing to live with him let him not
divorce her and a woman who has a
husband who does not believe if he is
willing to live with her let her not
divorce him for the unbelieving husband
is Sanctified by the wife and the
unbelieving wife is Sanctified by the
husband otherwise your children would be
unclean but now they are holy but if the
unbeliever departs let him depart a
brother or a sister is not under bondage
in such cases but God has called us to
peace for how do you know o wife whether
you will save your husband husband or
how do you know o husband whether you
will save your wife be patient with your
husband remain faithful to God and
remember that it is the holy spirit's
job to convict rest assured that God
wants to see your husband saved even
more than you do beautiful answer and
you here you are you have a wife you go
for Sabbath finally praise God praise
God Amen and you do your Sabbath walks
and I like that there's a lovely wife
thank you beautiful answer now if you
have just tuned in and you want to know
how to get in contact with us or you
have a Bible question you'd like to send
to us you can send a text to
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv and if you're an Instagram
person let's see you can Instagram
3abn underscore official thank you all
right here we go here's our last
question for each of you okay pastor
Loma King are you ready I'm ready okay
here we go
we know that Satan was one of the
covering cherub does the bible tell us
who the other one was Tracy from
Tennessee sure let's start with Ezekiel
25 18 and this is in the context of the
king of tire which is a parabolic way of
describing the work of Lucifer the work
of Satan also along with Isaiah chapter
14. so let me start with Verse 18 and
19. it says actually Exodus 25 verse 18
and 19 talking about the the sanctuary
excuse me
it says you shall make two cherubim of
gold of hammered work you shall make
them at the two ends of the mercy seat
so in the most holy place you find two
ends of The Mercy Seat you have two
cherub the covering cherub they're
referred to as and we know as you just
mentioned in the question that Lucifer
was one of the cherubs that covered we
find that in Ezekiel 28 verse 12. son of
man take up a lamentation for the king
of tire and say to him thus says the
Lord God you are the Seal of perfection
full of wisdom and perfect and Beauty
you are in Eden the Garden of God every
precious stone was your covering and he
mentions all the stones and then verse
you are the anointed cherub who covers I
established you you are on the Holy
Mountain of God you walked back and
forth in the midst of the fiery Stones
now in the Old Testament you don't find
any specific name given as to who the
other
covering cherub
might have been
right but the Bible alludes in a certain
way
for example
if you go to Luke 1 verse 19 and this is
when the message was coming to Mary
about the expectation of being with
child right notice what verse 19 of Luke
1 says and the angel
answered and said to him speaking that
is to Joseph I am Gabriel notice what he
says who stands in the presence of God
and was sent to speak to you and bring
you these Glad Tidings now it's not to
say that the other Angels don't stand in
the presence of God but I find it
unusual that it's referred to that way
because Lucifer was the one that had
more direct access walked back and forth
in the midst of the fiery Stones the
Bible doesn't say or referred to a
Gabriel as the other covering cherub but
I find also that he is used in scripture
when the names are given to Angels
Gabriel is the one that's continually
named Daniel 8 in verse 16. I heard a
man's voice between the banks of the Eli
who called and said Gabriel make this
man understand the vision that is the
Angel Gabriel speaking to Daniel and
then you find in Luke 1 verse 19 and 26
I just talked about that in a moment ago
but let me bring verse 26 in now in the
sixth month the angel Gabriel was sent
by God to a city of Galilee named
Nazareth I don't want to go into
speculation but clearly what I'm
understanding here if I were to if I
were to decide or give a name which I
would not do because I may be making a
decision that's not in harmony with the
support of the scriptures I would say
Gabriel seems to be one that could be
the other covering cherub the Bible
doesn't say he was but to walk the one
who stands in the presence of God seems
like an unusual way to say that when all
the other angels are there too Gabriel
had the I believe had one of the
blessings that Lucifer once had standing
in the presence of God but that's my
opinion and these are the scriptures
many scholars exactly and that's the
opinion of also many scholars yes I have
a correction you said in um Luke Chapter
1 Verse 18 you said he said it to Joseph
uh 19 sorry 19. is he was talking to
Zachariah Zechariah thank you honey yeah
he was talking to Zacharias thank you
appreciate that that's why we study our
Bibles together
thank you good answer thank you so much
okay Shelly here we go
will Satan be completely destroyed at
the end of time or just rendered
incapable or useless in his efforts to
deceive humans anymore this is from
Jenny in Washington oh Jenny that's a
great question and the Bible gives us a
great answer Romans 16 20 says the God
of Peace will soon cross Satan under our
seat Satan's final comeuppance here his
final destruction happens after the
Millennium when he is cast into the Lake
of Fire and perishes Revelation 2010 the
devil who deceived them was cast into
the lake of fire and brimstone where the
Beast and the false prophet are and they
will be tormented day and night forever
and ever well wait a minute if they're
going to be tormented forever and ever
that doesn't sound like he's being
destroyed but here's the point the word
forever an eternal in the Greek is a
relative word we might say relative let
me give you a relative word tall the
Statue of Liberty is 305 feet tall a
chihuahua puppies four four inches tall
it's relative when forever is used about
God because he is eternal it means
infinite when forever is used of a
mortal or a perishable thing it means
only until but the person exists we see
Jude 7 Sodom and Gomorrah are set forth
quote as an example suffering the
Vengeance of
Eternal fire are they on fire today no
because the fire only burned until
everything there perished so at one time
God cleansed the Earth
with a lake of water during the flood at
the end of time he is going to cleanse
the Earth
with a lake of fire he's going to turn
the earth into a lake of fire and it
will not be quenched until it does its
work so send Satan and sinners will be
purged they will perish Jesus said in
John 3 16. there's only one of two ways
he said for God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believed in him should not
perish that's right but have everlasting
life you're either going to have
everlasting life or you're going to
perish Revelation describes the final
punishment of Hellfire as the second
death for the wicked in Revelation 2 11
20 verse 6 20 verse 14 and 21 verse 8.
and I just have to add this
Ezekiel 33 verse 11. the god of love and
mercy takes no pleasure in the death of
the wicked Isaiah 28 21 says that day of
disaster will be his unusually strange
act and Malachi 4 1-3 says this behold
the day is coming burning like an oven
all the proud all who do wickedly will
be stubble and the day which is coming
shall burn them up that will lead them
neither root nor Brands you shall
trample the wicked for they shall be
ashes Under The Souls of your feet on
the day that I do this says the Lord of
hosts thank you neither root no Branch
none of it okay Jason let's go let's go
okay my extended family thinks that
every time we speak I mention God so
they don't want to talk to me
am I supposed to tone it down
I have to praise God who has given me
this wonderful Mercy this is from
Anthony
all right so Anthony I've got seven
quick points for you respect their
perspective Romans chapter 12 verse 18
says if it is possible as much as
depends on you live peaceably with all
men First Corinthians chapter 9 verses
22 and 23 to the week I became as weak
that I might win the week I have become
all things to all men that I might by
all means save some now this I do for
the gospel's sake that I may be partaker
of it with you be sensitive in timing
Ecclesiastes chapter 3 verse 1 says to
everything there is a season a time for
every purpose under Heaven Colossians
chapter 4 verse 6 let your speech always
be with Grace seasoned with salt that
you may know how you ought to answer
each one listen and engage this is
important James chapter 1 verse 19 so
then my beloved loved Brethren let every
man be swift to hear slow to speak and
slow to wrath Proverbs chapter 18 verse
13 He Who answers a matter before he
hears it it is folly and shame to him
this is important as well lead by
example Matthew chapter 5 verse 16 says
let your light so shine before men that
they may see your good works and glorify
your father in Heaven have an open
dialogue First Peter chapter 3 verse 15
says but sanctify the Lord God in your
hearts and always be ready to give a
defense to everyone who asks you a
reason for the hope that is in you with
meekness and fear Proverbs chapter 15
verse 1 a soft answer turns away wrath
but a harsh word stirs up anger pray for
wisdom James chapter 1 verse 5 says if
any of you lacks wisdom let him ask of
God who gives to all liberally and with
without reproach and it will be given to
him Colossians chapter 4 verse 2
continue earnestly in prayer being
vigilant in it with Thanksgiving and
number seven do not covet the job of the
Holy Spirit John chapter 16 verses 7 to
9 nevertheless I tell you the truth it
is to your advantage that I go away for
if I do not go away the helper will not
come to you but if I depart I will send
him to you and when he has come he will
convict the world of sin and of
righteousness and of Judgment of sin
because they do not believe in me ah
well done wasn't that well done I
enjoyed that thank you Jason
okay we are going to take a break and
when we come back we're going to hear
from our wonderful panel some few a few
final words we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
wow we've come to the end of this
program and I'd like to have our guests
give a short final thought Jason pray
for wisdom God wants us to understand
his word yes
uh there are two aspects of
righteousness by faith justification by
faith and sanctification by faith and I
praise the Lord that Jesus very much is
god without him we would all be lost
amen amen thank you for tuning in today
thank you my illustrious guests you did
a wonderful job as did you praise God
Amen and remember this is your network
we love you and we look forward to
seeing you if not here in the Kingdom
have a blessed day in Jesus
[Music]
thank you